all right so what's going on here they
give you this probability you're like
start at 65 then go to somewhere and
you're like what's this somewhere that I
go to maybe the maybe the probability
density function tells me what my
endpoint is except it doesn't the
probability density function from memory
it just has this boundary on one side
and then it's got no boundary on the
other side is that right yep now here's
what you really need to think carefully
about what function you're integrating
and what you can therefore know about it
even if you are even if you're like not
sure where this goes okay
and this function here what might it
look like even vaguely have a think
about this for a second 15,000 X minus
50 on X to the power of 4 now what I
know about it why I notice that and I
want you to think back to graphing
techniques and it was a little while ago
okay this is one of our rational
functions do you remember with rational
functions actually with all functions we
had to look for a few particular
features remember that we gave you like
a little acronym for it right we look
for the shape we look for intercepts
what is this guy do you mean what this
one was when it's a stay for a sense for
asymptotes right now as I'm sure it's a
particularly relevant when you're
looking at Exponential's when you look
at logarithms or when you're looking at
these guys rational functions okay and I
know we went over that fairly quickly
when we were doing the topics that's why
I thought it's worth dwelling on now
there are broadly speaking for us there
are two kinds of asymptotes right if I
asked you to graph saying one over X can
you like motion in the air we depend
like what would one over X look like on
the Cartesian plane
what's that thing it'll look like well
like this is this a shape we've known
since you're 10 right yeah okay good
this is um it's kind of hyperbola
looking shape like so right there are
two asymptotes where are they
yeah I've actually conveniently already
drawn them right and another color here
one is the y-axis so it's a vertical
asymptote and then the other one is the
x-axis right okay now I want you to
particularly think about like we know
where this x equals zero this vertical
axis sorry asymptote comes from it comes
from the fact that you're not allowed to
put zero into the denominator you're
like oh it blows up okay but what about
this one like how do we know what's
going on with the horizontal asymptote
I'm calling on knowledge from a while
back so I wonder max what do you think
in what said again max whatever x over
oh oh I know what your case oh you're
thinking about um in this example
doesn't help but um you're thinking
about dividing the top and the bottom by
the same power to try and like get rid
of like what's what's going on here in
this example it's not particularly
helpful because you you end up exactly
that we started but in other examples it
does work we what you're trying to do is
you try to understand if I put in really
it's a simpler way of doing it but it's
a bit messy and dirty if I put in really
large values of X in this direction or
in this direction for that matter X
equals 100 or x equals a thousand these
are some of the examples we actually did
in life you remember what's this thing
doing as you get larger and larger
values of X it's a protein you're
perfect right which is why I've got this
zero asymptote right now I want you to
use that kind of thinking on this guy on
our probability density function what is
happening when I'm putting bigger and
bigger values of X into this guy hmm
it's also going to approach zero isn't
it and the reason is for the exactly the
same reason is this guy right here the
denominator gets Spig and the numerator
just doesn't go anywhere right so if
you're a big denominator your numbers
very tiny that's why your perjurer the
logic is slightly different here as X
gets really big the numerator does
increase in size but what's the
denominator doing
in comparison like you think about this
right so there's like a tug-of-war
between the numerator and the
denominator right in this case the
numerator is doing nothing it's just
sitting there it's like three
denominator wins
okay now this numerators it's pullin
right it's getting bigger but what's the
denominator doing getting really big
this is like me on the other end of a
rope of a sumo wrestler right like this
numerous is gonna win okay so the
denominator gets huge this whole
function what does it tend toward just
like this guy you're tense was here does
that make sense
okay so therefore all of that to say
when you form your integral right it's a
bit sneaky the notation here gets a bit
flaky we're gonna start at 65 and go to
the right yeah do you agree with that
cuz you're like I need to be greater
than 65 but off the top here just be
very cautious with this right I'm trying
to understand what happens when I go on
forever and ever and ever does that make
sense I use infinity as kind of like a
shorthand for that infinity is not a
number I can't actually put it into my
primitive once I get it but we've just
gone through a process of understanding
if you go to really really large values
I know what this thing is doing it's
going towards zip does that make sense
so this is going to end up giving you
you get whatever I haven't actually well
it's gonna be that right from 65 up to
infinity right you'll put in your that's
the end point you'll put in your F of 65
to do this but then from this we know
what that's going to go to what it's
going to get to zero isn't it does that
make sense like this is what F of if you
could evaluate F of infinity and take
infinity as if it were a number and pop
it into your calculator it would hand
you back zero the limit would anyway I
can't my calculator can't do that but I
know that's what's supposed to do and
then I'm gonna subtract because that's
what intercourse - does that make sense
I don't think I did the most succinct
job it explained what we did before
right what's the issue with this and
also thanks to drain what's what's
another way to have a go at this right
remember set the scene right you've got
some
density function right it's defined in
some way but only in a certain domain
from 50 and then off you go right now
then they present you this and you're
like hmm that's a bit strange because
I'm gonna go from 65 onwards but then
this guy doesn't tell you all you ended
a hundred or you ended a thousand it
just seems to keep on going forever in
that direction right so how do we deal
with this the first method which we sort
of talked about before is and it's it's
a little bit sneaky you start at 65
because that's the leftmost part of it
right but that you you imagine or you
take the limit of what happens as you go
to infinity I just need to emphasize
again infant is not a number that we're
actually putting in but we know how it
behaves as we get close to infinity so
you get this right now because you can't
just put in infinity you run into some
problems when you try this next step
right you're like oh what do i do from
my upper battery but we said for this
particular function you have to look
closely and what probability density
function you've got as you get question
to infinity you just get closer to zero
okay so that's going to be your F of
infinity your upper bound and then you
do your lower bound and then off you go
okay you'll get an answer out of this
and I double checked from missing a
15,000 in my working this does give you
the correct answer but there's another
way to do it remember that even though
this looks a bit weird the rest of the
probability like before 65 and after 50
that part is very well-defined right
from 50 to 65 I could work that out
quite easily now the reason why it's
handy to work out that probability from
50 to 65 is because after 65 and before
65 covers your entire probability does
that make sense that's everything right
so therefore that's one do you agree the
entire probability in the situation has
to be one so this probability plus this
probability
that should equal two unknown value it
should equal one so if this is the thing
I'm actually after all I have to do is
just rearrange and subtract this from
both sides does that make sense I'm
gonna find my desired probability by
saying it's one takeaway this particular
integral in here and we have a name for
this when we think about probabilities
when you've got two probabilities that
add up to the entire situation right
what's the probability of rain and the
probability of not rain they add up to
one we call these two things
complimentary do you remember that idea
I'm complement with an e okay that's
important enough that I should write it
down so this method in here also works
and what's great about it is you don't
have to fuss around with this weirdness
of infinity in here I will just put a
note in as to why you might still care
about this and you'll see why on exactly
the next line what happens when you go
to evaluate this guy well this is just a
normal integral so I'm going to go from
50 up to 65 and I want you to notice
what happens on my next line of working
it's one takeaway and then you evaluate
both boundaries yeah so in this case
it'll be F of 65 takeaway F of 50 is
omegas okay now I've got some double
negatives here so I'll just tidy up a
teeny a little bit but I just want to
put the point of contrast between this
line and this line you will miss you
will get the same answer out both ways
misses these and I checked but if you
think back to the original question what
this actual thing was and the primitive
you get out of it it's really gross it's
like a pain to put into your calculator
and often these functions are right so
you can see that the the slight edge
that this method has is that you just
don't have to do true boundaries or you
did want boundary and you know it ends
up being zero okay so in terms of a work
minimization the amount of working you
put down is very small um this concept
is actually a really good way to do it
because it tackles what we know about
probability and both absolutely work
okay but I'm just going to leave that
out there that both methods
Valon